Mito the middle east's version of NATO
no longer exists founded by turkey and
Iraq it existed for over 24 years before
it dissolved in the late 1970s this
Alliance was similar to Nato in that its
primary purpose was to contain Soviets
and communist expansion in the region
however given that the alliance's
primary objective hadn't been achieved
by the late 1970s why did Mito collapse
so in early 1955 turkey in the Kingdom
of Iraq signed a defense agreement to
increase cooperation in case of unwanted
foreign intervention this was aimed at
the USSR which was funding Republican
groups in Iraq and strongly dislike
turkey's control over the Bosphorus this
agreement was known unofficially as the
Baghdad pact given that that's where its
headquarters were and a few months later
a new member joined the United Kingdom
now obviously the UK joining a Middle
Eastern Alliance seems a bit odd but the
alliance was never limited to just
nations in the region Mito was always
open to any country which had an
interest in resisting the expansion of
Communism in the region Britain still
held territories there and didn't want
decolonization to mean the rise of
communism them this also meant the
membership was open to the United States
which declined the U.S knew that if it
joined as a full member the alliance
would be painted as little more than an
extension of American power and so it
opted to Simply Be an observer to the
treaty that said Britain's involvement
did mean that many neighboring Nations
wanted nothing to do with the alliance
the most notable of these was Egypt
which in 1956 was invaded by Britain and
so naturally opposed the alliance
entirely and this Invasion meant the
very few neighboring states saw Mito
favorably many were concerned that
Israel would be allowed to join or that
they'd be forced to house Turkish or
British troops and given that many
Middle Eastern Nations had spent a long
time trying to get rid of the British or
the Turkish it just sounded like a new
form of imperialism shortly after
Britain joined Mito Pakistan and Iran
did too the plan then was to expand
until most of the Arab League had joined
but this never happened so why well the
first problem was that integration was
never that deep besides Britain and
turkey sidelining some troops in case of
conflict with the USSR in the region
there wasn't a unified structure or much
military cooperation the second problem
was that a mere three years after
joining a a rocket a coup its monarchy
was overthrown and the new government
withdrew from the treaty thus Sankara
became the headquarters of the alliance
which was renamed to Cento Iraq soon
worked with the USSR Egypt and Syria to
pressure other nations not to join the
treaty which worked furthermore when
Pakistan and India started shooting at
each other in 1965 Pakistan invoked the
alliance to help a request which was
refused which meant that Pakistan's
place in the alliance was largely
irrelevant after this the alliance was
unofficially dead but it wasn't until
the 1970s that it truly fell apart after
turkey invaded Cyprus in 1974 Britain
said it would no longer provide troops
or weapons to the rest of the alliance
and five years later after the Shah was
overthrown the new Iranian government
withdrew and Pakistan did the same the
day after to keep relations with
tehran's new government positive and
shortly after that Britain and turkey
opted to dissolve the alliance thereby
ending the middle east's version of NATO
I hope you enjoyed this episode with the
special thanks to my patrons James
bizzinet Kelly moneymaker kosher wolf
cartoitska Alex Schwinn Andy McGehee
Jerry lambdim Rodney Martin a firefly
Marcus arsner why in hockey space The
Lightfoot Marvin Casal Captain Sido
kumun Yoon Winston K would miss izet
boogly Wiggly Maggie pascowski the
macquapo Gustav Swan calling Dr Howard
Dr Fine Dr Howard Coppertone shuenin
spinning three plates words about books
podcast Jim Stromberg words about books
podcast and Charles the first